[Music]
welcome back to a very special episode
of care for boys where we are very
careful boys
today we're talking about how your
parents ask you to do [ __ ] but then they
never teach you how to do it and how it
[ __ ] you up and how you're in therapy
about it okay
one of the things that i remember um
i always got in trouble for is not
having common sense and then i would
argue and say you're supposed to teach
me common sense and i would get my ass
beat because i was talking back and i'm
like this weird loop of like i don't
even know what to do right and then you
tell me to go do it and i do it
and then i'm wrong for it at the same
time so i remember telling my mom that
and then she goes
i don't even know what kind of sense you
need to learn because i would be like
how am i supposed to do things if you
don't teach me the right way right and
it's one of my favorite things as a kid
when we first i just live in gardena we
moved to uh cerritos in our front yard
there's like these you know those birds
of paradise oh yeah so the bottom was
these lava rocks that are like this
small right
and the when we moved in the previous
owners they left a really cool tennis
racket in the garage
so like
we all know where this is going
i never have them before birds in
paradise so i would take no no it has
nothing to do with paradise but so i
take the tennis racket and i'll take the
lava rock and i would go whack and i
would see it fly across the street onto
my neighbor's roof and then it would
come down like a pinball machine like
like a plinko and i'm trying to like win
all the points
and then i would land in the driveway
and then so that would build i would
start doing more and more and more and
then i realized
when the neighbor was going to leave and
her car came out
when she drove over the lava rocks i
loved the crunching sound
so i would fill her driveway up with the
lava rock and then i would go inside and
just wait and listen and then she'd be
like
and i'm like yes
and then we got her and then one day i
think she ratted me out i
how does she know that because it's only
coming from one direction
and it looks like she walks over looks
at the birds of paradise
and it leads the rocks by the leads to
his [ __ ] house look looks inside the
window box like
no bart's like this
and then so my mom whips my ass but then
i go see this is why i can't do anything
right cause you don't teach me
all the extra [ __ ] you added that's so i
like that you have the common sense
enough to know that you don't have
comments i know but then i'm also like
it's like you do want your parents to
teach you the lessons but there's a lot
of big blanks between each one of those
that it as a parent it's hard to fill
out there's no way to predict that you
would have done any of that if he had an
ipad in his hands he never done any of
it honestly that's why it's good that's
the power of technology but
you would have just spotted something
being a board kid enough where you
singularly hit all the lava rocks into a
lady's driveway that was so sick that's
purely because there's nothing on tv
you know
it was so fun that when our like my
friends like you want to come play
tennis i'm like i'll show you something
that's funner with the tennis racket
you got some lava rocks at your house
i hate that you you had brought i feel
like i i got triggered or scarred with
this one thing you said don't talk back
yeah
everybody else get that from their
parents oh [ __ ] yeah couldn't say
anything yeah the [ __ ] weirdest thing
because they'll make me so angry because
any time you're right is when don't talk
back comes out don't talk back it
doesn't come out when you're like uh
wrong or or when you're in the middle of
like whatever it is you're doing it's
when you get right about what you're
doing and then your parents don't want
you to be right or they just need you to
learn some other [ __ ] giant lesson
that you have no bearing on because
you're only thinking small-minded yeah
you just gotta memorize whatever the
[ __ ] they're saying yeah yeah don't talk
about it no i always felt like
when i have kids i'm gonna let them talk
i would let them talk back to me
no i won't tell you
i totally won't but just don't talk back
that was the [ __ ] worst thing ever
and then my sister started saying it to
me too and i was like you're not a
parent yeah did you ever do anything
though did you ever like
release some of it somehow
like [ __ ] you longer
what'd you do with it once you're pent
up it never released on my dad because
my dad would beat the [ __ ] my mom would
hit me but like i still would like talk
back but then i'll get hit some more but
when my dad came home i'll get [ __ ]
whooped so i just remember
uh when i was finally taller than him is
when like he stopped hitting me and then
i remember he looked me in the eye one
time he's like you want to hit me don't
you and i was that that's when i chose
not to talk back and i didn't say
anything because i kind of did and i was
like
and after that i never talked back again
but i also knew they would never hit me
again my parents what the [ __ ] out of me
but there's one time i just couldn't um
like i had to let a little bit of steam
out so after my mom yelled at me i was
like leaving the kitchen
and then i just turned the lights off
that's the only way i was like they're
like [ __ ] [ __ ]
lecturing me and i'm like [ __ ] i want to
say some [ __ ] bro i can't
oh
and then she beat the [ __ ]
and i'm like brother
[Laughter]
what's the most creative
creative way your parents have
like inflicted pain on
anything and everything bro they would
grab anything to beat the shadow of me i
didn't get beat by my parents but i do
remember my brother um
me and my sister used to play this game
where we would lock my little brothers
out of the house
it was super funny especially because
especially yeah especially because my
parents weren't home and so we were in
charge and so and they're both working
so we're like we're gonna lock these
little [ __ ] out of here and we'll
just live it up in here but you can't
just live it up you have to acknowledge
that you're inside and they're not and
they're slamming on the door like their
life depends on it
they'll never get to eat drink go to the
bathroom ever again in their life and
they're going to die of starvation
outside
i'm like 13 my brother's like 11 my
other brother's like seven right and so
we're yeah we're doing that [ __ ] well
then my brother nate he uh
he i was i'm like you know in the winter
i'm like [ __ ] like i'm inside you're
outside and i'm like getting like a
little thing like a coke and i'm like
classic stephen
[ __ ] pissing this [ __ ] off well
i pissed him off so hard that he um
he
put his hand through the [ __ ] window
to punch me and he didn't know that he
was gonna break the window and he put
his hand to the window and then after
that
all i did was tell him about how dad's
gonna kill him and how he only has i'm
like dude you have like three hours to
live like what are you gonna do with
like the last three hours you're right
it's crazy
and then and then when my dad got home
not even kidding i actually did this i
was like oh [ __ ] dad's home and i was
like
[Music]
i played
i play this [ __ ] music as my dad
walks through the door
yeah you've been a troll since 13 oh my
god
that's playing people's hearts walks in
he's like what are we watching star wars
what [ __ ] are we doing you know
so did he beat his ass though nah he was
actually pretty cool but i was really
disappointed yeah your dad was close
super cool about it yeah he's cool about
it because of the star wars if i do that
[ __ ] i wouldn't even exist today i
thought it would disintegrate i thought
i was gonna lose my brother i was like
this is gonna be awesome because he's
like oh my son's not a [ __ ] [ __ ] he
punched through a [ __ ] window oh i
guess you could low-key be proud of that
i don't remember enough to tell you all
i remember is
building it up this much and being like
so like oh boy let's go yeah and then
like nothing really happened that is so
disappointing so disappointing your
brother's hand didn't get messed up from
the window even we were surprised that
was mostly what they were saying what
they're concerned about oh so that's
probably why they weren't mad because
they were like well at least he's not
heard and then after that they put him
in fighting they're like dude siblings
are the [ __ ] worst though dude i was
the worst for sure oh big brothers are
even crazier man i remember every time i
went home from school i was like oh [ __ ]
i gotta find a way to get into my room
as fast as possible because my brother
will like be hiding in the [ __ ] like
behind the couch or some [ __ ] and as
soon as i get through the door i'm like
hi mom never [ __ ] jump up grab me
pull my [ __ ] underwear and stick it
over my head or he found out another way
where he could pull my underwear my
balls would be hurting right he would
pull my underwear get my feet stick it
behind the underwear where you're like
hog flexible kid yeah and i'm just stuck
there and i'm like [ __ ]
i can't imagine the physics of this yeah
it looks like it looks like this like
when you when you got your feet behind
your like that you get your underwear
and you tuck it like that
oh my god that's [ __ ] funny though
yeah it was [ __ ] hilarious right
dude it was crazy and then he would have
um
you know like um the couch the futon so
he would pull out that that bed right
and then underneath there's a hole so
what you would find is a way to stuff me
under there and then basically keep me
under the couch and i'm stuck
oh my god it was like being buried alive
he buried a lot
we're all like yeah it's funny
he's like it was so fun don't you guys
remember you had to be there man i
definitely never did the pickup by the
underwear thing i can't believe i didn't
it was so cliche i can't believe i never
did that at one time the wedgie thing
yeah you never mind
never i never even thought i hated
wedgies i didn't know you could even do
that like i thought it was only in the
movies where you put that over someone's
head today's video is brought to you by
curology so i've been using curology for
my skin care for the last three years i
use it to wash my face i use it to
moisturize i use it and i have a
specific cool formula just for my
specific needs of my delicate skin guys
if you want ultra easy skincare that's
actually made for your skin curology is
the way to go you'll get a custom
prescription cream made for you by a
dermatology provider for your specific
goals whether that's tackling acne
clogged pores skin texture dark spots
fine lines or something else you start
by taking a short online skin quiz still
ship you your formula right to your door
so i got a special formula that deals
with my aging skin my wrinkles my
dryness and it's pretty cool because you
know i take this quick little survey and
they ask me what my needs are and then
they have my cool little formula that i
use just for me and it's been working i
think so get started with curology just
like we did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com
off the record just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com off the record to start your
free 30-day trial cancel any time
prescription is subject to consultation
did your parents ever make you got
amazing this is super asian but um get
on your knees and just like chill on
your knees all the time you mean as a
form of punishment it literally looks
like you have to like face a [ __ ]
corner and you have to be on your knees
but not sitting on your heels and you
have to cross your arms like this yeah
it's like it's like a age asian timeout
my mom made me i remember timeout but
then painful timeout i was in
kindergarten
and my sisters were doing like a snowman
like uh
project with spoons and they had to
decorate a spoon as a snowman okay and i
thought i was all funny and they had
these little like cotton balls and i
just was like dude they're gonna [ __ ]
this is gonna kill and i would put them
up my nose and then i'd be like yeah
and it got stuck
and then i couldn't get you you're the
kind of kid that put legos up your nose
yeah yeah i got a bucket stuck on my
head too that's a whole nother story but
i put the cotton balls in my nose and i
couldn't breathe oh sh and i was but i
was a mouth breeder anyway
i was like scared and i was like crying
and i was like
and they they finally got it out and
then my mom made me
this is the first incident where she
made me start doing this and then that
was my punishment for like a good amount
of time which she would make me squat in
the corner and pull my ears that's why
your ear gets so big when i want to kill
your ears for i don't know
i don't know
you guys didn't do that
no nobody
don't you love being the age though
where you're sitting there cause i
remember i was sitting there one time
and i'm like i don't know probably six
or seven years old and i'm looking at
like a christmas stocking and i see
those little bells on it and i'm like
i have a theory
so i grab one of the bells and i put it
in my mouth and i swallow it and then i
start jumping up and down to see if i
can hear it
[Laughter]
did you have a stomachache
it was like really small i didn't have a
stomach ache and then i walked into my
mom and i was like how come if you
swallow a bell you can't even [ __ ]
hear me jumping up and down
and she's like stephen what did you do i
swallowed like one of those little bells
you can't even hear nothing
and she's she was immediately like oh my
gosh she grabs like the merc manual and
all this [ __ ] she starts like calling my
dad at work and she's like
what do we got what do we do
oh my god you're vomiting it out or [ __ ]
i guess i shoot it out but we didn't
have to go anywhere if you never [ __ ] if
you [ __ ] it out and it finally break
please there it is and then steve pulls
out the [ __ ] puts it back on the
stockings
[Laughter]
but i love being that agent just seeing
something and going i have a scientific
theory and i would like to put it into
practice with no control i remember like
kids common sense like that where like i
first learned about like the garbage
disposal my mom's like don't put
anything in there
and i'm like in my mind i go i go yes
but then in my mind it's like why not
yeah
and then i would like take a chopstick i
would turn up
oh [ __ ] oh my god and then i was like oh
my damn it's stronger than wood
i remember throwing a fork in there and
then i broke it and then i got my ass
before it's just i thought i told you
not to put anything in there and i was
like i know that's the reason why
you're crazy that could have been so
dangerous bro they had these commercials
like i don't know 2000s or some [ __ ]
where they had
people
putting a cake into a dishwasher and
then they opened the cake and they
opened the dishwasher and then the
cake's all gone and everything's all
clean in there because they're basically
showing like this is a [ __ ]
dishwasher bro
that's the oil commercial yeah so i we
had my mom used to go to costco and she
would get like all these like pies at
costco like 20 pies
so i think you can imagine where this is
going
so i put one of those 20 dollar [ __ ]
uh apple pies into the into the at the
bottom of the dishwasher and there's
nothing else in there just about i just
want to see if it
[Laughter]
by the way the pie was still in there
oh sh it's full of [ __ ] but i remember
my uncle telling me some dumbass [ __ ]
right because he was trying to tell me
like movies
comics all these things can influence
you because he's like when i was your
age
he's like me and my buddies you know we
finally got to see superman and then
he's like we man we believe that we
could fly and i'm already thinking at my
age
dude you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] right like
no one everyone knows you can't fly but
then he's like yeah like everyone
believed that we could fly and so me and
my buddy we went up
on top of the roof of this house
and then we're like
fire on the count of three we're gonna
go and we're gonna fly and then they're
like really so sure that they're they
could fly like superman they both
[ __ ] jumped and broke both of their
[ __ ] legs
right
and then that was his
example of like this is why you
shouldn't watch movies and comics and
things like that are because i'm an
idiot because he's like he's like
because i don't want you to believe that
you can fly and i'm like
i'm not a [ __ ] idiot like you like
what the [ __ ] wow that's first of all if
you really can't fly you know you don't
have to fly from a high place i know
right like why would you jump from there
what's with that why do people always
think they have to fly from a very very
high place they gotta get a head start
they gotta get a jump start terminal
velocity man
you have to reach it even as a kid i was
like
you are so stupid
there was a kid at my school who did the
same thing i just
jumped up and jumped off yeah you're
flying yeah i don't know if it's time
you tried to like jump into a pool and
miss the pool but literally a kid showed
up in a wheelchair with two broken legs
and then that was just the story of the
whole high school like he thought he
could fly yeah yeah does every high
school have one of those i think so
we've had one in our middle school yeah
maybe it was middle school i hope it was
man this was elementary for me i just
remember somebody being like hey that
keeps having to fly you know what's
funny with with childhood common sense
is how angry you get as a kid when
people don't believe you yeah okay and
like uh when i was i was like single
digit age my sister was two years older
than me she had a like a school project
that was made out of milk cartons and
like hangers or something i kept telling
her to do it differently and she was
like it's not your project shut up i got
so mad at her that i pulled her hair
band off you know like those little
horseshoe shaped hairbands i yanked it
off and i tossed it across the house and
then it went all the way across the
house and on a table leg it went
and then i went oh and i was like
telling her i threw your hairband and
look how it's like right around the
thing and she was like stop lying that
didn't happen and i got so filled with
rage that she didn't believe me because
i'd never i'd never seen something so it
was a perfect shot that i went to her
her whole project and i went
and tore the whole thing apart
dude my dad my dad came home and she all
she said was that
oh ryan got mad and he broke my project
and i was like you didn't even tell him
about the hairpin
and like as if it justified it i was
like no dad i saw i threw it from
liberty to the family room and i was
like trying to explain this thing he's
like let me explain something to you if
you actually did that i would let this
[ __ ]
do it again go ahead do it again right
hoping it would like make it worth it
and then my dad was like he got super
pissed he took one of the hangers from
the uh from the project and then he
pulled my like short leg back and he
goes he goes this is gonna show up on
your leg and he went bat and it was a
perfect [ __ ] hanger shape on my thigh
that's pretty cool
and i called the
cops was your dad like holy [ __ ] it's
the perfect hater things they didn't see
the [ __ ]
the cops come he's like yeah i did do
that it's pretty good and it should have
been dude perfect family
i hela called the police and then they
showed up and
my dad goes what's the [ __ ] like where
are the cops here and then this is like
i feel like there's 1992 or something so
they would have been on your dad's side
yeah they were instantly on my dad's
side they opened the door they go uh did
your son call the cops and then i'm i'm
in the back like trying to get the cop's
attention and show him my leg
and then my dad's like i have to
discipline him because he destroyed his
sister's project and then they just
started having a dad to dad
they were like
kids can be pretty crazy they were just
talking forever like what i like to do
is i put a towel on first so they feel
the pain but there's no more
you know that bart how do you know that
bart
i like to take a bed sheet fill it with
soap bars
beat the [ __ ] out
to a kid you're like
justice is served [ __ ] and it's
like when you're watching like like a
cop show and the and the the bad guy is
about to get caught and then the cop is
like friends with the bad guy and you're
like no yeah oh no
it's like every time the cops were at
dahmer's house and then dahmer was
instantly like they just fell in love
with each other like oh [ __ ] but i don't
know if you guys ever been in that
situation where the cops are like you
think the cops are gonna save you and
then right when they say bye to each
other and your dad's closing the door
you think i'm about to be [ __ ] killed
did he murk you afterwards no he just
they did that [ __ ] stare and they
just went to his room and i went i'm
gonna i'll never know what i'm gonna die
now like it could happen in my sleep if
i see that door closed i'm already
opening the back door
if i see that door closed i'm already
like here's my other leg
he ever went beyond like so like if your
parents can't save you cops can't save
you maybe god can save you but if god
didn't answer your prayer did you ever
go to like santa claus or something
because i prayed to the [ __ ] ferrari
poster on my wall one time
because i was that desperate yeah i
literally was like
i'll be like santa claus you don't have
to give me nothing for christmas
just for real [ __ ] save me just one
time bro
this is the christmas gift i need
how many gods failed you for you to turn
to a ferrari poster all of them
all of them dude every single one where
am i [ __ ] up elrond hubbard
i was that desperate i really did that
because i was like holy i thought my
life was just so [ __ ] and then uh
after i did that i was like oh [ __ ] i
just broke a major commandment
because that's one of the ten you don't
do that yeah you know false idols dude
so then like i had to confess that i
only followed the first five that's why
god's quiet
five commandments i picked i'm a
buzzfeed article dog i don't go over top
five commandments
top five commandments that's the next
otr
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you